all right hi guys i'm madman
[Music]
hello there issue two of batman fortnite
zero point has dropped
which means it's time to delve back into
the world of batman catwoman and harley
quinn
to recap their adventures and to point
out things you may have missed
if you haven't watched part one i'll
link that and remember at the end of all
six issues
i plan to remake the story totally in
fortnite
so sit your butt down for 10 minutes
slap code adamaru in the store to be
named at the end of the video
and let's break down issue 2 of batman
fortnite
zero point
the last episode in the saga saw batman
and catwoman embrace
as the storm ate them alive and here's
the first shot of this issue
ring any bells can you find the location
on the island to me i'd say
this is here at weeping woods the
problem is
this season is primal and this location
is currently changed we spoke about this
last episode
that the comic book was likely drawn and
written many seasons ago
before the order was confirmed anyway on
with the story
batman awakes in this new spot without
any recollection of the last loop
but quickly finds notes written on his
armor in his own handwriting
this happened before and you have 22
minutes
so many loops have passed that the
etchings are so precise they include
coordinates
and here is something to note if batman
wrote these
which hand did he use try this for
yourself use your dominant hand to write
your name
now try with the other hand yep it looks
like a toddler wrote it
well this means mr bruce wayne is
officially ambidextrous he can write
with both hands perfectly
and i don't know why i think it's
i think it's because of batman
batman quickly reads the messages he
sent to himself and within moments
understands the loop he's in and the
parameters of the game
like being unable to remember and unable
to speak
he also notes that his armor is battle
scarred concluding the island is full of
combatants
and this is confirmed when ruckus tries
to sneak attack on bersie
who then gives him a knee to the face
and this is where we need to note
another thing about the loop from the
first issue
at the beginning of issue 1 on page 5
harley quinn smashes bruce in the face
with her knee
and yep once again on page 5 of issue 2
it's another knee to the face this time
with batman turning the tables and
landing a blow
that can only be described as grunk
there's also another repeat to this loop
batman's first opponent ruckus the guy
eating the knee
was also his first opponent in the first
loop
that time he took a reverse turning kick
to the chest
the ruckus time loop comes back in the
story later on too after defeating
ruckus batman runs to the coordinates
like frodo going to mordor
i'm going on an adventure
batman finds his very own batcave
version 1 or the bat
shed if you prefer bruce is still a
little uncertain if this is a trick by
his captors
or a hint from a previous version of
himself inside we see much investigation
work has begun
this must be from tens if not hundreds
of loops of work
considering he only gets 22 minutes this
can be found in game right now
but the shacks have key differences the
general layout is the same the clock
above the door the 1980s pc
and the chalkboard too but the version
in game is set loops before the version
in the comic book the notes on the wall
the string investigations are not here
in game right now
but there are the next best thing
fishing posters i guess it's only a
matter of time until batman loses his
mind
take a look at this jesus christ
oh looky here the random llama plushie
in the bat shed
batman really does have this random toy
llama statue
thing will it be important in the future
or does batman just need a little
companionship the most important clue of
all is scrawled on this wood chip
the cat is a friend batman grabs his
analysis device which
looks to be based on a sony handycam
from the 1980s
and off he goes on another adventure to
find the cat
[Music]
over the next crest are six people
fighting his first thought is the cat
must be the seven foot adonis mousels
batman quickly deduces
that's the wrong cat but let's stop on
this panel for a moment look it has the
fortnite hood on screen the mini map
the compass and confirms batman has one
elimination
he did defeat ruckus but there's
something more important here
look how many characters are still alive
five which quickly goes down to 4
when catwoman brutally takes out bright
bomber
batman correctly believes catwoman is
his ally but this time catwoman does not
pause like in issue 1
she takes the fight to batman just like
the previous issue
the fight is interrupted by the storm
the purple glow pushing closer after 20
minutes inside the loop
batman goes big brain here and uses his
batarangs as a notepad and pen
and writes the bat is a friend giving it
to selena
in the hopes she'll keep it in the next
loop let's stop for a moment and notice
another thing
we know that memories are wiped between
each loop but if batman's suit can be
marked and ripped
and they can give items to each
character that means that anything we
bring into the world can be traded and
kept the next page in the story sees
batman on the next loop
having already reached the bat shed as
he leaves to find catwoman again
a batarang hits the door frame the cat
has found the bat
this time around without a single word
between the two they begin working
together
the animal spandex duo head around the
island each loop
looking for answers heading past the
shark landmark which
once again isn't on the island in the
same way this season
r.i.p continuity their plan is simple
take a closer look at the storm
to see if they would be reset the panel
goes black so i'm pretty sure that test
was confirmed but before the cycle ends
batman makes it to first base
is first base hand-holding i've never
played baseball in my life i think
that's what it means
the next loop sees the duo search in the
waters around the island
batman is looking for hatches and my
dude totally misses the very real hatch
in game right now which is here and i'm
sure you've seen the other ones all over
the island
so he gives up on the idea at least for
now by the way this shot
is by the sweaty sands pier batman is
getting around
we really should question the
rebreathers batman and catwoman use here
it's becoming a running tradition for
epic to foreshadow new items in
promotional material around the game
for example the crafting function we all
use now
was seen all the way back in 2019
and the p1000 fast forward a year or two
and look it's in game could rebreathers
be part of an event
maybe a mechanic in future seasons
underwater fights
could finally be a real thing one day
all thanks to batman
oh i like this page in the comic book
series and i have no idea why
we should take note that their armor
continues to degrade at this point
catwoman is gonna need to cover up soon
to keep this
family friendly while all this is
happening we must remember the bond
between batman and catwoman is all
maintained without
a single word or memory
suddenly selena barges into bruce their
truce is finally over
but heck no the flamboyant feline saw an
incoming squad and dove to save him
as she dies batman turns into a fit of
rage and launches at the squad
batman knows she'll be alive in the next
cycle but that doesn't stop him from
going absolutely back
crazy a thing we should note here is how
batman uses weaponry
pro tip hold the gun by the muzzle who
needs bullets
this guy can do anything it's almost
like a batman
during this emotional outburst we
receive a little more law
batman realizes emotions carry over
between loops
each cycle resets our memories but our
feelings do carry over
that explains the growing bond between
him and selena
i don't know what that means but it just
sounds nice
onto the next cycle and this time the
duo are scaling the heights of steamy
stacks
batman uses the method of walking up a
building in homage to the scenes on the
tv show of course these were actually
filmed on the ground with the camera
rotated to appear to be climbing on a
sheer building side
this is how we did that that you didn't
know
bats and cats spend the next few moments
kind of avoiding each other
like they know something happened in the
last cycle but of course they can't
remember it
the caped crusader whips out his butt
oculus and takes in the view
watching a familiar face fragging below
harley quinn
we haven't seen her since she dove into
the void in issue one
she is absolutely in her element right
now oh and hold up a minute look at the
weapon
an smg with a sniper scope and a bayonet
i know this is just a comic book series
but hey i would love that weapon in
fortnite
selena also feels the connection to
harley and the duo jump down to
try and speak to her which will be hard
as they're all muted
uh-oh harley suddenly embraces fortnite
dancing
which dance do you think she rocks
during this fight scene is it a
take the l b the default dance rc
the floss it's the floss harley quinn is
flossing in fortnite
in an official batman dc comic book
series
we've come a long way since 2017. batman
jumps down to face harley catching her
bat
and presenting her with a batarang just
like he did with catwoman
this is a trap help us find a way out
harley isn't interested in the slightest
and headbutts brucey boy
right in the nose and then eats him into
the storm
before he's overcome he writes another
note telling future batman's
to ignore harley and concentrate on the
storm
the next loop sees our heroes in the bat
shed doing quantum physics or something
there's actually a breakdown of all the
storm circles here and their duration on
the board
does anyone want a fact check it looks
good to me the next storm circle takes
us to lazy lake
and there's some more law here catwoman
whips out batman's multi-tool
no that's not a euphemism and she places
it in the very center of the closing
storm circle
their plan is simple to see if an object
left in the center of the final circle
survives into the next round and sure
enough they are right the next cycle
they revisit
and there it is still here so therefore
another piece of law is confirmed
there is a safety mechanism in the very
final circle
it's such a revelation that the duo
actually smile at each other
the next time they try this with a human
they stand gazing
into each other's eyes in the final
circle to see what happens
but this is another epic failure so they
reset
but this time batman wants to see what
happens if a single person survives
in the final two with catwoman he walks
away into the storm
to catwoman's despair he even throws up
a talk to the hand
as he walks into the void
talk to the hand as batman reaches death
he
looks back to see a shimmering light
around selena
the vic roy is hers confirming this
theory
the battle can only be won by a single
survivor
batman must be new to battle royale
games we've known this forever
the final loop of the episode sees the
storm circle end at coral castle the
last remaining characters yet again
are batman and catwoman but this time
batman lifts a knife in selena's hands
he wants her to get this epic victory
royale in return for that vic roy
he makes it to second base results a
little bit of smooching time for batsy
but then he's stabbed in the heart which
is what dating feels like
most of the time right catwoman is
declared the winner and the storm glow
covers her
we don't see what happens next as this
story is told through the eyes of batman
he awakens back on the island back with
no memory
back at the start of the issue he
attempts to understand his emotions
but this is cut short by an attack from
ruckus
the same man he's faced three times in a
row now
the issue ends will catwoman find batman
and tell him the secret
has she escaped the loop or is all this
futile
find out next time on batman fortnite
zero point
[Music]
so that's what i found this week
hopefully that recap was useful and you
noticed a few things you didn't before
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been an absolute pleasure here's a bunch
of names of people who kindly used my
code adamaru in the store this week i
really appreciate you
you made this video possible thank you
so much i'll see you soon for issue 3.
see ya
[Music]
you